A sneaky Cyberpunk 2077 reference and a
seer with a prophecy to end the world of
the Witcher. "The Witcher: Blood Origin"
hid some insane details in its storyline.
A particularly joyous Easter egg comes in the
third episode of "The Witcher: Blood Origin," when
the show's hodgepodge team of unlikely misfits
strategize over how to defeat an interdimensional
monster. With the group all but accepting
their powerlessness, Brother Death offers,
"Why don't we poison a sheep and feed it to it?"
The moment is a funny one on its own, but it
becomes even funnier when you realize that
the idea is a direct reference to both the
"Witcher" books and the main Netflix series,
which feature the very same sheep-based strategy.
In "The Bounds of Reason," a short story
in the book "Sword of Destiny," Geralt
and a large band of adventurers
hunt for an alleged golden dragon
that has been terrorizing a small
village. Before Geralt's arrival,
a local named Sheepbagger had filled a
dead sheep with a number of poisons, which
apparently worked and killed the dragon. Geralt
arrives as another dragon begins attacking anew,
and once again, Sheepbagger offers a poisoned
sheep as a plan. The story is adapted for the
sixth episode of Season 1 of "The Witcher," this
time without Sheepbagger and his ovine offense.
As "The Witcher: Blood Origin" begins, we're
treated to a surprise scene starring everyone's
favorite lecherous bard, Jaskier, in the modern
era. Though he's saved from a chaotic scene
of blood and death, it's obvious that he isn't
out of the woods when his rescuer is revealed:
the mysterious figure played by Minnie Driver. Her
rescue is as horrifying as the battle before it,
as is her inestimable amount of magic power, much
of which she shares with another mysterious figure
from the Witcher lore: Gaunter O'Dimm
from the video game "The Witcher III."
In the game, O'Dimm takes a special interest
in Geralt, which he never quite explains and
results in the figure helping and harming the
Witcher's quest according to his whim. Likewise,
Driver's character takes a special interest
in Jaskier, which she also never explains,
aside from calling herself a fellow storyteller.
They both upend the lives of their chosen mortals,
and they display a striking amount of
similarities in their godlike powers and
dubious morality. Both display the
ability to freeze time completely,
and both wander freely among the frozen
populace, aiding or killing them at will.
On the other hand, this mysterious
character might not be a reference to
O'Dimm at all. After first appearing to
Jaskier in his own form, she tells him,
"I have other faces ... if you prefer."
The combination of that shape and that
mask strongly resembles the Crones,
or Ladies of the Wood, from "The Witcher
III," specifically the hulking Brewess.
Brewess and her two sisters may have
been referenced on Netflix before,
in the form of the Cabin Witch from Season 2
of "The Witcher." All these characters share
a number of traits, many of which can be
traced back to the Slavic folklore figure
Baba Yaga. Whether or not this new character
is revealed to be one of the Crones or not,
she is certainly a part of the Netflix
series' habit of hinting at their existence.
In "The Witcher: Blood Origin," there is
no character whose importance to the story
is more significant than it seems than
Avallac'h, the young Elvish apprentice.
Fans of the books and video games alike
will recognize the name as one of the most
important in the history of Elvendom,
and specifically the history of Ciri.
In both the books and video games, Avallac'h
is an old Elf with an immense amount of magical
knowledge and power. More so in the games,
he becomes Ciri's mentor and protector,
teaching her how to safely wield her powers
and keeping them from falling into the wrong
hands. Given the young Avallac'h's appearance
in the post-credits scene of the miniseries's
last episode, he may yet fulfill some of the same
grand duties as his counterparts in other media.
Another small role in "The Witcher: Blood Origin"
is Ithlinne. The young girl appears only briefly
in the first and last episodes, bookending
the miniseries with quick teases at her true
nature. In both episodes, she enters trances
and delivers prophecies to Éile, The Lark,
demonstrating a natural magical affinity
and the rare gift of foresight. However,
for fans of the books, games, and other
media, Ithlinne and her prophecies mean
so much more than mere guidance to
a single Elf warrior — they're the
reason for all the machinations that
end up enveloping Ciri and Geralt.
Though the Ithlinne we meet in the series is
just a young girl, she'll grow up to become
the greatest seer of her age, and potentially
in the history of the Witcher timeline. She's
known for a number of prophecies that come
true, but more than anything for one that
has yet to come true. Simply known as
Ithlinne's Prophecy, it reads in part,
In the eyes of many of the Continent's wisest
and most powerful, that Elder Blood must be Ciri,
meaning whoever controls Ciri, controls
the ending and rebirth of the world.
It's thanks to the old Elven mage Balor that
we hear one of the most subtle Easter eggs
in all of "The Witcher: Blood Origin." The
mage is selfish, ruthless, power-hungry,
and spiteful, which is why, after he banishes
political rival Eredin to another world,
he can't resist one final curse. As he
expels Eredin and his men, Balor adds,
"Wherever this takes you, may
you burn for all eternity."
For Witcher fans who know Eredin's
destiny, the line is ironic and cheeky.
The Eredin in the books, games, and other media
eventually becomes The King of the Wild Hunt,
a title given to him for not only commanding
the fearsome raiding party the Wild Hunt,
but for leading their attacks from
the front as an ancient king might.
The irony in Balor's last curse upon Eredin comes
in how the Wild Hunt operates: all their raids
are fought with frost magic. Specifically, they
use pieces of the all-consuming White Frost to
inflict devastating premature winters on their
targets, turn them to ice using frost magic,
and even employ dog-like ice elementals
as their frontline offense. Not only is
Eredin not burning for all eternity, he's
actually freezing more than almost anyone.
It's no secret to those who pay attention
that the elves of the Witcher world are
heavily inspired by Celtic mythology and
actual Irish history. Their place-names,
surnames, and even the name of their species
are overwhelmingly Gaelic. For example,
the two main races of elves are known as the Aen
Seidhe — an obvious play on the aes sídhe, the
fairy folk in Celtic mythology, whose name
literally means "people of the mound" — and
the Aen Elle, also a play on the same,
this time meaning "people of the alders."
In "The Witcher: Blood Origin," the connection
between elves and Ireland is taken a step further
by the Lark's song, "The Black Rose." The bard
sings the ballad multiple times throughout the
miniseries and ultimately inspires revolution
among the lower-class citizens. The title of
the song is intentionally referential to Irish
culture: the Black Rose is a well-known symbol
for Ireland itself, and the subject of
one of its most famous tunes. The song,
written in or around the 16th century,
has become a traditional Irish ballad,
and as such, has become an integral
part of the country's folk tradition.
Because "The Witcher: Blood Origin" introduces
the first Witcher to ever prowl the Continent,
it naturally has to also introduce
the first Trial of the Grasses:
the process by which Witchers are made. In one
fascinating Easter egg, it turns out that the
ingredients that went into this first beta
test of a Trial share a lot in common with
the ingredient list detailed in "The Witcher
III" — set 1,200 years after this series. When
Zacaré and the rest of the team gather herbs
to begin the Trial, she claims to require,
"There are Feainnewedd flowers in this cave,
but I'll need you to collect mandrake root,
wolf's-bane, and corpse nettle and we'll need
the heart of the beast back at the monolith."
When Geralt and company try to recreate this
Decoction of the Grasses in "The Witcher III,"
the recipe is similar. Mandrake root
remains, as does the body part of a
monster. The major difference seems to be that
later Witchers find common plants sufficient
substitutes for the much rarer wolf's-bane,
corpse nettle, and Feainnewedd flowers.
Though Avallac'h has relatively little screen
time and plot importance in "The Witcher:
Blood Origin," one line of dialogue he just barely
manages to finish is one of the series's coolest
Easter eggs. After he's allowed to pore over the
writings of the brilliant mage Syndril regarding
interdimensional travel, Avallac'h excitedly
reports to Queen Merwyn that the Conjunctions
might allow for time travel, as well as
interdimensional transit. The small detail
you might have missed here is that Avallac'h
is actually right — and Ciri has proven it.
In one of the more emotional scenes in
"The Witcher III," Geralt and Ciri share
a deep fireside talk, having just
reunited after years apart. As Ciri
recalls her pursuit by the Wild Hunt and the
protection of Avallac'h, she tells Geralt,
"He found a portal and took us to a
world where Eredin couldn't find us."
When Geralt asks her about
that world, Ciri recalls that
"People there had metal in their heads,
waged war from a distance using things similar
to megascopes. And there were no horses. "
Though Geralt doesn't believe her, Ciri is
telling the truth — she traveled into the future,
and as many fans believe, that future
is the setting of "Cyberpunk 2077."
One interesting phenomenon that appears twice
in "The Witcher: Blood Origin" is the concept
of celestial twins. The first instance comes when
Balor tries to provide some unknown godlike deity
with an appropriate sacrifice in exchange for
power. The mage offers the unseen force a pair
of celestial siblings, thinking their cosmic
importance to be an adequate payment. Though
he ends up being wrong, at least in the eyes of
the mysterious being, it's clear that celestial
siblings are thought to hold an abundance
of magical power. When it's revealed that
Syndril and Zacaré are also celestial twins, and
that both their magical abilities are bolstered
by that connection, Balor is confirmed to
be right. However, fans of the core series,
"The Witcher," may already recognize celestial
siblings and the powerful destiny they share.
In the first episode of "The Witcher,"
Geralt is tasked with capturing Renfri,
herself a celestial twin. The power behind
celestial twins lies in the date of their birth,
especially in the moon on the night
of their birth, and for Renfri,
her birth came during a prophesied
eclipse known as the Black Sun.
It's a hard and fast rule within the Witcher
canon that women cannot become Witchers. According
to the lore of the books, women are simply not
strong enough to endure the Trial of the Grasses,
let alone the myriad other challenges
that follow, and are therefore never even
considered for the job. Luckily for gender
equality, and for common sense in general,
"The Witcher: Blood Origin" has finally
taken a canon position to the contrary.
When Syndril and Zacaré suggest creating
a monster to fight Balor's creature,
they hint that only the strongest among them
has even the slightest hope of surviving the
transformation. Based on that knowledge,
the group agrees that Éile, the Lark,
is the best candidate. That means that the first
Witcher to grace the continent is originally
supposed to be female. It is only because Éile is
so beloved by Fjall, who can't bear the thought
of her dying or becoming a monster, that he
sneakily undergoes the trial in her place. So the
first Witcher ends up male, and the ridiculous
idea that women can't be Witchers takes hold.